S'il te plaît, ma princesse impuissante, ils me portent
Mon épaule est chaude, il faut le prendre
[musique]
L'idée des unités mobiles est venue des bus
Et l'enseignant mobile après un tremblement de terre dévastateur qui a touché
Affecte négativement les centres éducatifs et les écoles
dans la région
Les unités mobiles assurent un service éducatif
Il apporte également un soutien psychologique aux enfants
Les personnes touchées par le tremblement de terre
Nous étions encore en vie. Ce tremblement de terre s'est produit et la structure s'est effondrée.
Nous n'avions plus de maison et nous leur avons donné un logement et une école
Elle était devenue très loin d'elle, et cette simplicité lui venait
Voici notre mère, nous étudions, et il y a beaucoup de beaux tapis et nous étudions
Et nous apprenons
Ils nous apprennent beaucoup de leçons
[musique]